en este vídeo demostraremos un par de
hechos simples acerca de paralelo gramos
pero que están muy relacionados entre sí
vamos a empezar con este dibujo aquí
tenemos un paralelogramo bcb y tenemos
que probar que la longitud de ave es
igual a la bbc esta es igual a ésta y la
bbc es igual al área de esta es igual a
esta o sea que los lados opuestos miden
lo mismo vale bueno para realizar esta
prueba vamos a trazar la diagonal b de
la diagonal b de ba bueno esta diagonal
además de ser una diagonal la podemos
pensar como una línea transversal a la
pareja de rectas paralelas a b y c de y
ya que son paralelas podemos concluir
que sus ángulos alternos internos son
iguales es decir que el ángulo a vd este
de acá es igual al ángulo b de c a este
de acá déjame escribirlo de este lado
tenemos que el ángulo ángulo
es igual al ángulo c d b
de ve muy bien de manera similar esta
diagonal también es una línea
transversal para la pareja de rectas
paralelas a de ibc como es paralelogramo
veces paralela a ade y por lo tanto
ahora estos ángulos el adb y el dbc
también son congruentes entonces a dv
y este de acá es congruente al cb de al
cb de déjame apuntarlo por aquí
dv
de v es igual al
cb deje el ángulo
de estas dos afirmaciones de aquí son
por ángulos ángulos
alternos alternos internos e internos
vale bueno ahora porque esto es
interesante porque observa además esta
recta verde pues es igual a sí misma
déjame marcarlo eso eso suena un poco
raro pero esta es igual a sí misma
entonces observa los triángulos a dv y
cpd comparten este ángulo este ángulo y
además el lado b de entonces son
congruentes eso está padrísimo verdad
déjame apuntarlo por acá me voy a poner
con este color rojo y tenemos que el
triángulo
de b nos vamos de aquí al naranja al
azul es congruente es congruente a éste
al naranja y al azul al cdb al triángulo
se ve b y esto se debe justo al criterio
de congruencia
criterio de congruencia
ángulo lado ángulo sale coinciden en los
naranjas el lado intermedio y en los
ángulos azules bueno y porque está padre
que los dos triángulos sean congruentes
pues porque esto nos dice que todas sus
partes correspondientes también son
congruentes entonces observa el el lado
ave es el correspondiente al cde
entonces gracias a eso podemos concluir
lo voy a poner con color amarillo que
ave ave es igual a cd acb
también podemos concluir que el bc el bc
es igual a el de a al d
sale esto de aquí lo voy a poner que es
por por digamos la dos lados de
triángulos triángulos congruentes
y eso es justo lo que queríamos
demostrar que los lados opuestos eran
iguales ya tenemos a b y c de ave igual
a c de ibc veces igual la deja muy bien
entonces ya demostramos esta parte de la
afirmación déjame pasar al siguiente
problema que está muy relacionado mira
aquí nos dice que en un paralelogramo
los lados opuestos miden lo mismo pero
el siguiente problema dice que si los
lados opuestos miden lo mismo éste es
igual a éste y éste es igual a éste
entonces es un paralelogramo o sea que
ave es paralelo a cede y que bc es
paralelo a ade muy bien la prueba va a
ser bastante similar otra vez vamos a
empezar trazando la diagonal déjame
tomar el color amarillo para trazar la
diagonal sabemos más de triángulos que
quede que para él logramos verdad
entonces es bueno conseguir los varios
triángulos entonces aquí tenemos que el
paralelogramo se partió en estos dos
triángulos y observa estos triángulos
comparten de este lado el ade y el bc
comparten este lado el ave con el cde
pero además comparten esta diagonal
de la del pd le voy a poner triple raya
porque ya use una y dos pero entonces
justo estos dos triángulos ahora son
congruentes por el criterio lll no voy a
poner aquí le voy a poner que el
triángulo voy a tomar este este lápiz
que el triángulo a d
b d es congruente es congruente al
triángulo c b b en triángulo se me ve
muy bien y esto está padre porque deja
dejarle pongo aquí porque o sea esto de
aquí esto de aquí sucede por el criterio
lll por criterio criterio lll pero esto
está padre porque ahora todas sus partes
también van a ser congruentes en
particular este ángulo el ave de lo voy
a poner con con azul el ave de este
ángulo de acá va a ser igual al pdc a
este de acá entonces lo pongo aquí que
el ángulo ave de ave de es igual al
ángulo ctv c de b también tenemos la
igualdad de estos ángulos los voy a
pintar en naranja el adc
el atv mejor lo pongo con rojo que no lo
he usado a debe es congruente al al cb
de este de acá entonces el ángulo debe
es igual al ángulo cvd se ve de estas
dos afirmaciones son por ángulos ángulos
correspondientes correspondientes entre
ángulos congruentes lo voy a poner así
muchas abreviaciones pero bueno se
entiende la idea y bueno que podemos
deducir a partir de que este ángulo sea
igual a éste y éste sea igual a éste
pues otra vez usamos el argumento de
ángulos internos alternos pero ahora al
revés o sea tenemos que que la recta a b
y las sedes son una pareja de rectas
donde verde es una transversal este
ángulo es igual a este entonces tenemos
ángulos alternos internos iguales y por
lo tanto podemos concluir que
qué ave es paralela a cd no voy a poner
en color azul entonces tenemos que ave
ave es paralela a cede le voy a poner la
raya para referirnos al segmento o bien
la recta y también tenemos lo mismo pero
para para a de ibc también tenemos que a
de ade es paralela abc abc porque esta
diagonal esta diagonal es una
transversal que tiene ángulos iguales
aquí y aquí entonces son ángulos
alternos internos iguales y por tanto a
d es paralela a abc si quieres lo
escribo de este lado esto es por ángulos
ángulos alternos alternos internos de
los vale entonces con eso concluimos que
es paralela abc que ave es paralela a
cede y por lo tanto voy a ponerle aquí
abajo por lo tanto a veces de
paralelogramo
lee lo gran
entonces está muy bonita la conclusión o
sea ya tenemos que si es para l logramos
entonces los lados opuestos son iguales
este con este y este con este pero
también tenemos la afirmación al revés
que si los lados opuestos son iguales
este con este y este con este entonces
tenemos un paralelogramo vale ya lo
demostramos en las dos direcciones
déjame déjame pasarme para acá bueno lo
voy a lo voy a poner aquí mismo entonces
ya lo demostramos en las dos direcciones
y eso también se le conoce como un sí y
sólo sí a qué me refiero con esto que
puedes usar la frase que un cuadrilátero
abc de es un paralelogramo si sólo si
las parejas de lados opuestos son
congruentes vale ese sí sólo si quieres
decir que si es paralelo gramo
entonces las parejas de lados opuestos
son congruentes que es lo que probamos
arriba y además para que algo sea
paralelogramo basta con que las parejas
de lados opuestos sean congruentes vale
entonces tenemos un lado y el otro y eso
es justo lo que demostramos en este
vídeo